hello everybody we are going to get
started momentarily
and we're just going to wait
for this to get started say hi in the
chat i will try to pronounce your name
i'm not sure if i'm going to be able to
most of the time i can't
so people end up getting offended
i'm just going to close that out there
we go
hello jvs that's my admin on my discord
server
casper the ghost hello we're just gonna
wait for people to filter in
pair okay see i already can't i'm just
gonna call you pera
santi what's up patel hello logical
programmer
cardinal that is a moderator so you
better behave yourself
all right now they're just coming in too
quick but we have we're going to get
started very soon
very excited for this we already have
110 people watching
all right
all right logical programmer the first
high was enough
all righty i'm excited
from brazil
hello hello if you want to see my
discord server you can go to my youtube
channel which i'll show you in a second
all right wow 363 already watching
all right awesome so you know what
i think we're gonna go ahead and get
started
all right so first of all for those of
you who don't know me
and many of you do because i have my own
youtube channel i've been doing this
forever for the last 10 years
i'm gary simon i've been a ui ux
developer
and a front end developer as well
did i say ui ux developer i should say
designer and you and a front-end
developer as well for
the last 20 years and i've
been an instructor for the last 10 years
and i've produced many courses
um over 800 videos on my own youtube
channel
and my goal is just to help people
become better designers
and front-end developers but for this
stream
we're not going to be focused on
front-end development at all which is
strange because we're coming from free
code camp right
um that's what why i thought it would be
really interesting to do a live stream
here
where i introduced some design concepts
and the understanding of ui design
fundamentals to for
those of you who are front-end
developers or just programmers who have
an interest in design
alright so right here i'm showing you at
this
site designcourse.com it's going to be
relaunching very soon
in several months time if you want to
learn and you want to be able to be
notified when this officially launches
we're working on a hard now
enter your email go to designcourse.com
and you will be notified when it
launches
so here is my youtube channel you can
also i check this out it's just design
course the link is here in the
description of this video
and go ahead subscribe up watch my
channel i'm
usually uploading twice a week along
with am i
i do a live ui ux review usually
once uh a week maybe sometimes once
every two weeks
so it i'm going to be doing the same i
do the same show all the time on my own
channel so if you like this
go ahead and check that out and now
we're going to talk about
you know i something that plagues
a lot of uh beginning designers or
perhaps if you're a front-end developer
a programmer already
and you want to be able to design so i'm
going to first talk about something
that's going to sound
really unrelated tennis
all right so i'm sure many of you if you
ever tried to play tennis or
golf or bowling or any new sport
you're terrible at it at first i mean
your first time you show up
you're not sure how to hold the racket
hopefully you know at least to hold the
handle or the grip
i but you're just terrible at it right
and it's interesting because when it
comes to
ui design you're able to
watch and you're able to look at another
great design you're able to observe
and say hey that's a great design you're
able to look at a tennis player
like roger federer and say hey this guy
is a great player
so we're great at observing design
and sports in greatness i but we're
terrible
at creating it so why is that well
simply because you lack the muscle
memory and you also lack the
fundamentals the understanding of the
fundamentals
so when it comes to ui design
the reason that you can observe and say
hey that's a great design but you can't
create it yourself is because you lack
the fundamentals you lack the
understanding of ui
fundamentals and you also probably lack
the muscle memory you haven't done it
enough all right so
my goal in this stream is going to be to
help you
pinpoint the areas where you're failing
in your designs
all right and so this i can do this very
quickly i could take a look at most of
the designs i i haven't seen yet
and i'm going to be able to say okay
this is wrong this is wrong that's wrong
and so this is going to help you
understand
even if i'm not look if even if i'm not
critiquing your own designs
you're going to be able to basically
you're going to benefit from it
even though i'm going to be looking at
other people's designs so don't get dis
discouraged if your design wasn't chosen
so first of all how do you submit your
design
well you just go to twitter and the
hashtag
live ui ux review it's also mentioned
here
right there that's the hashtag that you
want to use live ui ux review
and just submit uh your design it could
be a live website
i it could be maybe a figma prototype or
it could be an adobe xd prototype or
whatever it could just be
a flat jpeg mock-up screenshot it's it's
really
i'm not too picky about that all right
so we already have a few
that we're going to get started with so
the very first actually the very first
entry came from roxanna and
this is uh what she produced
all right so we're going to close these
tennis players out
all right so this is her design as you
can see we're going down here oh by the
way
i will also ask you guys to rate it so
in the chat
here on youtube i'm going to ask you to
rate these designs from a scale of one
to ten
and i'm not gonna look at your answers
i'm not purposely going to not look at
your the uh the youtube chat
and then i'm gonna see if my answer
aligns with yours
all right so we'll get to that here in a
second so
i this is i'm not really sure exactly
about what's happening
it's obviously like a nutrition maybe a
diet sort of site a service of some sort
but i can notice a couple things right
away that are immediately wrong
first off is the navigation the
navigation you can see the links are
home
about us in meals however
there's not enough white space so when i
was talking about ui design fundamentals
and how
it's so important to understand those
things white space or sometimes referred
to as negative space
is one of those ui design fundamentals
so
there's not enough white space between
these elements
so if i kind of uh try to scale this up
a little bit more you see there's hardly
any white space up here they're really
cramped together
so that that that makes it difficult to
use which results in a ux
issue user experience issue so you want
to spread those out
further away from each other first and
foremost second off i would say it's a
little bit strange to have
this large area right here
i get out of here what are you doing
i'm trying to get that off there we go
all right this large circle right here
so i would definitely scale that down
because it's just
it's taking a lot of attention away from
the eye
to an area that's not that important the
search bar is not that important
next up we see we have this really cool
i like the design here and the the
creativity it's kind of like a graphic
design this is
a strong part of this page here so far
um but i think what needs to help to
be addressed here a little bit more so
is having a call to action
you should always have an area where
it's immediately identifiable
where the user should go whether that's
to click a link fill out a form
or scroll down now we do see right here
it says scroll
down with a tiny um little arrow but
that's not obvious enough
so you'd want to maybe perhaps take that
scroll down
area right here put it maybe underneath
this lorem ipsum text this descriptor
and with when you get into html and css
maybe make it animate up and down to
catch the tension of the eye
all right so coming down further you
would probably want to avoid
big walls of text like this um and also
if you do have
two paragraphs which you do you want to
create that white space that separation
between them
coming down further this part is pretty
good
like i said though a lot of people when
they're on a landing page and for a
service or an app or a website of some
sort they don't want to read a ton
when they're on the landing page they're
just kind of scrolling down so i would
probably reduce
the number of uh words that you have
here in the verbiage
um yeah and this is a pretty pretty good
though there's a lot of good things
happening i like the colors though
uh the color and contrast all is working
well i like the use of photographs so
there's a lot of good things happening
here
so what do you think this person should
get for a rating
let me know in the chat one being the
worst and then 10 being the best and
then i will
let you know here in about 10 to 15
seconds about what i think this one
should be rated
i should have the the uh jeopardy or
wait is that yeah the jeopardy dun dun
dun dun
okay i won't sing again sorry about that
for me
i'm gonna go ahead and
rate this one which i see nobody is
bothering to rate it
there we go we got run one rating i'm
going to give this one
there is a lot of white space in between
here probably too much between this as
well
okay i'm going to give this one a
6.6 yes i'm doing decimals somebody said
6.5 they got very close
but yeah pretty solid overall so thank
you for that submission
roxanna all right so next up
we have from a user of sama
let's click this all right
i'm going to refresh these just so if
there's any animation we'll see it
all right so this is from assam and this
is a
uh and it feels like i need to right
here we're at 100
zoom the default zoom i'm going to go
ahead and
increase this it feels like at this
viewport width which is you know i'm on
a 4k resolution monitor
i there's too much white space
around here so you want to fill this out
more and make sure you're adhering to
you know because this is an html css
javascript already you want to make sure
you're you're really
targeting all of the potential
uh viewport or the resolutions um and i
feel like you can probably
fill out the space more by making these
a little bit larger first and foremost
so you remember uh in the previous entry
when i talked about having a call to
action
we are lacking a call to action here
entirely
so first of all there's nowhere i can't
scroll down on this so it's just that
this one page right here or
above the fold so to speak um so i can't
scroll down
and all we have here is a an area
um where it says you know if you have
any questions uh or any queries feel
free to get in touch
on twitter or via email i'm going to
make this a little bit larger so we can
all see it
and then the email or the call to action
right here is just a plain text it's not
even an
ahref mailto form so it's not even a
clickable link
i this is the email so
this is a really bad call to action uh
because you want to make it as easy as
possible for people to contact you
especially
on the context of your portfolio where
you're trying to get work
you don't want people so this is a ux
issue this has nothing to do with ui
design
um you don't want people have to work
extra in order to hire you or contact
you
for a quote or just to hire you so
at the very least make this a clickable
link
but even more so than that the ideal
approach for here for this
situation is i would completely get rid
of the email
and i would put in a section uh
an actual clickable button that looks
like an identifiable button that really
stands out like a call to action button
should
uh where people click on it to view your
work
why would somebody contact you if they
don't know
if they haven't seen your portfolio so
that's a
big thing here so in terms of i
in ux there's something called
information architecture
also in terms of ad copy i i wouldn't be
directing them
to just contact you right away you do
have a link up here to your portfolio
but that's not good enough you you want
to make this main hero section as it's
called this whole section up here
you want to make it directed uh and
really focused
on the area that makes the most sense
for what the user wants
all right and sometimes you know we have
to make assumptions but
when it comes to you user experience
design you'd also
want to get feedback from real users
and say hey what are you most interested
in seeing
uh is it is it my email address or is it
maybe my portfolio
so i've done enough of these to know
that it's the portfolio that's the work
that they want to see the most
so put a link to your portfolio or a
button
that's real identifiable as an actual
button um and then also
i would put maybe a secondary um
call to action because you can have two
of them to your actual
i would say email address or a way to
contact you also another
side note when it comes to your
portfolios always have a way for them to
contact you with a form on your website
all right don't just put in an email
address or make them
click this to to load up their email why
they could be on their phones and maybe
their email client or they don't have an
email map app that's set up on their
phone
so that's a missed opportunity they
might forget when they get home
always have a form on your portfolio so
people can contact you
all right so that's really maybe
mainly this is a ux issue for the most
part looking at the ui design
and and how it's actually designed it's
it's not too bad i don't see anything
that's really coming out and just
you know being 100 percent wrong but
these are major ux
issues here so given what we've seen
here
what do you think this person should get
for our rating one being the worst and
10 being the very best
we'll see if most of you agree
all right let's see i think you know
i'm going to be factoring in the issues
of the ux
so this isn't just about what it looks
like it's about
you know those ux issues as well so on a
scale of 1 to 10
i'm probably going to rate this one
a i can see you guys are i'm not trying
i'm not looking at your your answers yet
i don't i don't want to be influenced by
other people i'm i'm just gonna say
a flat out
four all right now if i were only
looking at
the ui design you know it would be a
little bit higher than that
not much higher but the ux issues were
hurting it for me and it looks like a
lot of you
i pretty much agree i see a seven up
here
i see uh threes a bunch of threes
actually
so it looks like we were pretty much
agreeing for the most part
all right so let's close that one off
and
i'm going to pick out the next one and
again if you want to submit your design
i'm probably not going to get to it
because we have so many entries already
you can go ahead to twitter though and
do a live ui ux review
hashtag with your entry so
let's click on the next one
[Music]
all right i made this website for a
school please check it out
this is from ahmed
all right so what i think when i see
this design
which by the way i haven't seen it yet
this is the first time
i'm looking i i
i think to myself kind of a little bit
boring and bland
um with the gallery just kind of like a
gallery starting right away
i i think it doesn't have much semblance
of a structure structured ui design
where you know you're utilizing like a
hero section to do something interesting
and say something interesting
a lot of people if they didn't know
exactly what type of site this was
which i do because it's for school you
told me already
they wouldn't know right away what this
site is about
we i really wouldn't know i i don't know
what's happening by
the the logo so you're making people
guess
and again this comes down to a ux issue
i
you want people to know within the first
couple seconds
what this site is about i all i see is
somebody who's giving a speech it may
not have anything to do with school
so that's one of the things you want to
address with a strong headline
your ad copy is very very important uh
the copy that you use on your site
a strong headline sometimes you can use
a sub headline as well to
to elaborate a little bit more um but
just having a photograph here i just i
wouldn't do that
i try to try to actually formulate it
into
a situation where you have a nice hero
section um
you could still use a photograph maybe
as
as a watermark photograph or something
like that there's a lot of ways you can
approach it but you you want to address
what this site is about so i
we have pre-grade primary secondary
checking this out
clubs and societies all right so one
thing here
on this resolution i we're
looking at just the kind of the desktop
portion all these uh little blips where
you have a title
and then the description uh you could
put those side by side in at least two
columns that way you can save up
vertical space
um instead of having it all listed out
you would do this
for instance on the mobile version
because you just don't have enough space
to put them side by side
but you want to make sure you're really
wisely using all the space that you have
available
and then of course if you went all the
way out here then you could possibly
if you weren't using a fixed container
here you could possibly use three
columns
all right
all right so i think that's a good
review and outline of what's happening
here
the type here for the most part is
pretty good it's a very simple design so
it doesn't necessarily mean that it's
bad
it's a bad ui design or a bad ux design
actually
simple is great for you user experience
purposes
but i think that the one issue here is
what i mentioned first
and that is an issue of ux
i you want to address what people are
doing so what do you guys think this
person should get
factoring in the ui and the uxi issues
or the non-issues for this design one
being the worst and 10 being the very
best
i'll give you guys a few seconds to get
your answers in
and for me yeah by the way try not to
spam too much there
you there's no reason to spam your
answers don't worry i'm not picking out
any of you
individually to say uh you know
i i'm there's no reason to spam please
don't do that
just sit your answer once that's it
all right so for me i'm gonna give this
one
yeah again we're probably gonna have to
rate it on a little bit of lower side
just because you know the ux
issues and the ui design could be
improved so i'm gonna give this
one here just a flat out
4.8 or so maybe around five
it looks like i'm i'm actually being a
little bit nicer than you guys
or girl sorry um so yeah thank you for
that submission
the next one up is going to be from
i let's see ammer
and this one actually looks pretty
impressive so let's check it out
all right
all right so i'm going to refresh just
to see if there's any initial
animation there is a loading screen
right here all right so i program
websites
i create websites i develop websites
a little bit i would probably change
i would change that up a little bit
because some of those are a little bit
redundant
create and develop maybe design if you
do design
um what i thought was uh pretty
impressive about this is
right here i am a 15 years old front end
web developer so
this is a 15 year old who made this
and it looks pretty nice so definitely i
like what i see here especially from a
15 year old one thing i thought was a
little bit too
small just a tad bit on the small end is
it's the type here
on this resolution you should probably
be up right around here so
it's a little bit enlarged so i had to
use my my browser zoom
i'm at 150 percent so that's one thing
to think about
the call to action they definitely have
a good call to action that stands out
pretty well
i personally would probably make it
filled in by default and not outlined
just so it sticks out just a tad bit
more but that's
that's me splitting hairs um i program
so i like the headline it's a pretty
pretty unique headline um and then he
expands a little bit further on about
you know what exactly exactly his
expertises are which is a front-end web
developer
specialist at vue js and a freelancer so
this is pretty solid
um i just think it needs to be a little
bit larger um
so about me for me personally i think
that should be work we want to say
portfolio more than we want to know
so much about you um so you could put
two you could put two
uh buttons in here and one could be
outlined and then one could be filled in
because you do want to have a primary
call to action and that's emphasized
through
your ui design so
let's see what else i latest projects
all right simple enough
sometimes it's nice to have these kind
of in card formats
um so that they're not just
flat out screenshots that are placed on
here
um there's a lot of different ways but i
would suggest go into google and type in
ui design cards
and you might get uh some other ideas to
more interesting ideas to
to showcase the thumbnails and the
information along with them but this is
pretty
this is this is not that bad i mean i
hover over it i can see this
sometimes people instead of requiring a
person to hover
they'll put that at the bottom of the
card that way all the information is
right there
and you're not requiring extra action on
behalf of the visitor
um coming down here this is pretty good
i
so another ui design fundamental that's
extremely
important for everybody to understand is
what's called
visual hierarchy all right i talk about
this
all the time and if you're a coder and
you're new to ui design you probably
never heard of it but visual hierarchy
isn't just specific to ui design it
applies to all sorts of design like
graphic design and
print design all that stuff and
when it comes to visual hierarchy what
we're talking about is
we're using our ui design principles our
fundamentals
in order to place uh
emphasis on the most important elements
and also to separate
elements visually from each other so
visual hierarchy
i is very important to get right in
terms of your typography
so what i mean is we have web design
here
it's a larger font size so the scale
that's another ui design fundamental
and it's bold i it's larger than these
elements right here
so you can see there's a clear
separation between
the title and then also the
little informational blips underneath
them sometimes
you can you can even further
uh create a further separation between
two different elements
in order to create that visual hierarchy
through
color and contrast even so i can take
out my browser tools
and i can come down here and we could
change this color
maybe to slightly less white a little
bit less contrast and that will create a
further separation between those
elements
visually which reinforces the visual
hierarchy so let me show you
so we come down a little bit now if we
go down all like this
way too much we can see there's a
massive separation now between the title
and these blips underneath them but
that's
really bad for people who don't have
great
eyesight you know they have visual
impairments so you want to make sure you
adhere to a
minimum contrast rating uh the wcag 2.0
go ahead and research that it's the
minimum contrast
ratios that you should have uh so but we
can come out maybe right around here
if we go up here you can see they kind
of blend together the title and the
description or these
these the subtitles if you will but if
we come down here
it creates a nice little separation
between the two even further so
so that's just something to keep in mind
um i
might also take these these are
paragraphs
and they're separated by break elements
i would probably change that because
these are lists this is the front-end
development topic now
i would change these into unordered
lists because this is what they are
but the reason i'm mentioning that is
because you could probably separate
those out a little bit further a little
bit more white space
vertically between each other
the contact me all right so this is
extremely important
i'm really interested in what's going to
happen when i
click on one of these text fields
let's see enter your name
don't want to do that you want to have
at least a floating label
if you're going to have like this
placeholder item right here
you want to have it floating meaning
that when you click on it
it will automatically transition above
the text field because it's a ux
issue again it's an accessibility issue
because when you're you should never
rely just on placeholder values
for your your text fields and your your
form
elements i the reason being if
i start typing out my name
well i don't my name isn't my name is
gary
i maybe for some reason i come back or i
forget maybe i have memory issues
all of a sudden now i have no clue what
this text input is about
because there's no label there so the
best way to to fix this problem
either use floating labels or just use a
dedicated label
that's always visible and your form will
be your forms will perform much
better all right so good call to action
for the send button here
and yeah i think that's enough time on
this one what do you guys think this
person should get
a rating for one being the worst and 10
being the best
you could put your answers in on the
chat and
you'll see how we'll see how close we
align together
yeah there's no super chats here that's
for sure
okay i like what i like the dark theme i
really do
um the contrast is all working well
a lot of things are going right but
nobody gets better if i just talk about
what's right all the time
i really like this section this is this
is done well
for me i'm going to go ahead and give
this one a rating of
let's see how it behaves responsively
that's good
i like what i saw there
i'm just going to give this one a
it will be our highest rating so far i'm
going to give it like a 6.8 6.9
very good thank you for that submission
all right
so next up we have
from a user i build a bitcoin wallet
where users can send and receive
bitcoins with django
check it out and if you like it you can
check out the tutorial i made on how to
build a similar site on my channel
okay they're using some promotion here
all right so it's called ging wallet
ging wallet alrighty
let's refresh this to see if anything
interesting is happening
all right so
these carousels um on hero sections
i would opt to completely
i would get rid of that one thing
that's a big issue as well is the the
photographs
they're just redundant um they just
they're just bitcoins they all look the
same
i would get rid of that completely
instead
i would just use keep your keep your
headline one of these headlines here
have a sub headline
and if you want people to create an
account now
well have that be a part of your hero
section right here
definitely uh do that so notice
create an account now but it's not
linked anywhere
what is that about so you're going to
require people
unfortunately to go up here and click
register
uh in order to get their account set up
so by the way why is that
why is that what i can't even see
register the type so there's there's a
huge contrast that should be white
so why not i can guarantee you if if
you're sending traffic
to this website right now which you're
probably not um but if you were
and this is what you were launching with
i would be able to take your signups
probably increase them by like 500
percent
if we restructured this whole section
right here
and you got a person to put in maybe one
of those form fields
like the register perhaps with an email
um and then like a get started uh
that way you're utilizing it's so so
much better
um so that's my that's my review for
here what do you guys think this person
should get
for a rating one being the worst and 10
being the best
now me i'm i'm reading some of the
comments i'm not trying to
i'm not trying to ascertain if this is
legit or not i'm just looking at the ui
ux solely
don't go here and actually use this site
i want it's not even secure
for me i'm going to go ahead and give
this based on what i see
probably a
maybe like a 2.9 or a three or so
all right now let's check out
another one we have another personal
portfolio
so let's check this out casper the ghost
dot me all right so there was some
animation let's refresh it
all right so one thing right off the bat
that's a little bit
too fast refresh casper irvinson
web developer make it stick around maybe
a one to two seconds a little bit
more if you're going to have something
like that anyhow in the first place
all right so visual hierarchy that's one
of the things i was talking about
this is a good visual hierarchy between
these two elements
the the person's name which is kind of
like a label
and then front-end focused web
developers so those are done
pretty well however we have all the
space vertically
um what we want to do to fix
this issue is fix the um
the issue by the way is the fact that
there's not enough white space
separating the projects and contact
section the little buttons
the call to actions from the other two
elements up here
so what we want to do is we want to take
these
the button container we'll want to do a
margin top he only has 20 pixels
so we want to go maybe
i'm just going to use m units by the way
oops
like five maybe seven m units
yeah we'll just do six and now things
can breathe a lot easier
they're not so cluttered additionally
i i would use something like flexbox or
the grid the css grid to try to get this
push down
uh and center it vertically within this
container because it's just up high and
then there's hardly anything happening
down
here so again you know i wouldn't use
margin for this we'd use uh
place content center or something like
that but nonetheless margin top
you know we want to push this thing down
i
not 20 m units more like
uh 8m units or so and now
just take a look at this and i'm going
to refresh it so you can see
the original and just pay attention to
how this
just feel looks and feels so much better
so if i refresh
look how it's all just kind of you know
it's kind of cluttered up there it's
put at the up at the top so these are
the things
when it comes to ui design fundamentals
and understanding them and understanding
how to apply them
that really make or break a design i'm
not saying that this thing is completely
broken there's a lot of good things
happening here
but it can really complete a design so
looking at this here
i it was an issue of
alignment so this whole blip right here
was it's just on it's aligned up to the
top too much too high because
it's leaving an uneven amount of white
space down here
and also white space between these
elements right here
um coming down all right my backpack i
like being unique
uh in your in your copy so that's good
um
all right one thing i also don't like uh
which he's this person's not doing here
at all i
is a lot of portfolios that i've seen do
this thing where they show
progress bars for their skills
don't do that because you you don't
really want
you you might be ha you might maybe
you're trying to become hired at some
you know maybe google or whatever and
they really need
somebody who's proficient in javascript
but you're putting that you're 10
percent proficient in javascript i
wouldn't lay out my cards
like that because you're letting people
know what your absolute weak
weaknesses are if you're if you're a
front-end developer
and i you know maybe
you're not that great
at react maybe just don't put react
anyhow
all right so there's different ways to
do this i like okay if you're gonna do
this
that's fine i think the layout gets
broken a little bit when you shift it to
a second line right here so the ui
design kind of suffers from that
if you're going to have this many you
can probably use a carousel if you want
or just utilize uh or structure this in
a different manner to where it's not
uneven where you just have two on their
own down here
all right so now we have some cards
right here by the way okay and here's
something that we haven't faced yet
borders most of the time you don't want
to use
borders borders were something that were
really popular
you know back when i got started in the
late 90s and
the 2000s into the 2010s just about
before web 2.0 came along
but the borders you don't you completely
do not need this border right here
underneath projects i would
take that sucker out it's a border
bottom
so i'm going to hide that there you go
we've already now we've created
a pretty solid change here just by
getting rid of an unnecessary border
because it's completely unnecessary in
this context you don't need a border
here
i you have cards we have the label we
know
the cards are in relation to this label
so
you definitely want to get rid of your
borders another thing i would change
here
whenever you have two buttons i'm not
usually a big fan
especially in this context like on a
card of having them styled exactly the
same
because then it just becomes
overwhelming you have all these buttons
one should be secondary and not
emphasized as much
so maybe one is just the same color as
this background right here
with the view on npm being maybe white
or something and you can make
maybe have a border as well i along this
button
and that way one is a little bit more
emphasized over the other
coming down here this about me section
is
is quit pretty weak because all it is is
just a
a paragraph underneath it and it spans
the entire width practically of the
design
and reading that becomes a little bit of
a headache
so you could put a picture of yourself
like in a two-column layout
and then situate this stuff to the right
but there's a lot of ways you could
approach it but i wouldn't just
do this in and of itself
one thing it's also throwing me off the
about me is a little bit like gray
but the main content is white i would
reverse that
all right so i like this section the
most i'm not sure if you've used some
sort of like
um what do you call a library or some
type of
you know component that was pre-designed
but i do like this the most
all right so right here last thing the
form
probably i would take the especially on
this resolution
right here it makes sense to keep it
like that but when you have
it all the way out here these are really
long form fields take it
and create at least two columns take the
enter your name
your email can go right next to there
and that way you're saving space
vertically as well
but at least you are using the labels
which is great
all right so what do you think this
person should get for a rating one being
the worst and 10 being the
very best well the timeline is self-made
well that's very
uh that's impressive i like this
timeline a lot that's this right here is
the strongest part of this ui design
all right get your answers in i will
give mine
very shortly
i'm just looking at it and just trying
to think you know what do i think this
person should get
there's a lot of things happening right
here and the contrast
is is solved solid it's pretty simple
which isn't bad that's not a bad thing
i'm just going to give this one
a
6.5 i believe yeah right around there
now some people have asked me have i
ever given a 10
no i have not there's always some tiny
little issue that
i can uh i can pinpoint because trust me
i've done like 50
60 70 80 of these shows i i'm not really
sure how many
all right so let's check out who is next
i
all right
all right here's another portfolio this
is from megan
all right so if i refresh this we'll see
if there's any animation no there's not
which
i that that doesn't mean like there
should be i just like to show if there
is all right so
there is a that one issue that i
addressed before which is you're not
addressing
what what this site is exactly about i
know it's about you
but what is it that you do we need to be
a little bit more specific
about that i like that you're being you
know a little bit unique especially with
the
topography i like that part um but i do
think the navigation over here
can have it needs a little bit of work
just having these buttons kind of like
really separated out and each one of
them being their own button
encased in this design like that it
feels just a little bit
i guess you could say it's designed in a
manner that's kind of uh amateur i guess
you could say or
yeah just amateur i would say what i
would do in this context if
i were you and trust me this is one this
is a tip i haven't talked about this
here yet
gaining inspiration from other designers
so i'm going to show you a couple sites
dribble.com so most of you may know of
dribble.com but
it features some of the best uh ui
designers so if we go to the popular
section here you'll gain a lot of ideas
about different ui elements if you don't
see one maybe you're trying to work on a
vertical nav bar or sidebar
like megan has right here well
i vertical navigation like if i type in
vertical navigation
i'm probably going to see a lot of
different ideas for the designs
of vertical navigations and if something
really sticks out
well to you i'm not saying copy it pixel
for pixel
but gain inspiration from it when you're
a brand new designer and you try to come
up with
designs from scratch that's a very
that's a that's a tough ask i mean
you're putting a lot on yourself
if you're you're not an experienced
designer i'm not saying
don't don't screw my words up here i'm
not saying go out there and copy things
pixel for pixel
but i'm saying you need to expose
yourself to
other designs and other great designs
in that way you can start to develop an
eye
even if it's just through observation so
that you can start to apply
some of these to your own designs and in
fact i would say
like here here's here's a real nice
sidebars right here
these are really nice uh the way that
they're done
and really pay attention to why they're
doing the certain things they're doing
notice hers has these little icons right
here i'm gonna i'm gonna
zoom up so we can see this these have
nice icons as well
but each one of these being separated
out and being in their own buttons and
being real
far apart from each other kind of just
throws off the flow of this
this ui design i noticed how like a lot
of these
examples you know what you want to do is
look at similarities between these
examples
why do they look good why are they so
effective
well i could tell you one reason is
they're they're pretty close together
and they're not all in their in they're
not all encased
in their own individual buttons i and
and so that makes it simpler to use
um and they also provide a state maybe
you hover
over them they're going to have their
own little design where the background
changes in a very subtle manner
and maybe another manner where it's
actually selected
maybe that one sticks out a little bit
more but for this these are all
i really just encased in their own
little world because they're they're
separated out far apart and they're also
their own
uh project uh or the button rather uh so
that that's my review here you would
definitely want to change this
up um and also the the other thing that
i mentioned
let us know more specifically about what
you're doing what this website is for
rather than just being about you
all right so what do you guys think this
person should get for a rating one being
the worst and 10 being the best
where am i from i am from the united
states i live in ohio
one being the worst 10 being the best
i'll let you guys know what
i have that problem i say guys all the
time i'll let you people know
i i'll let you people know what i think
here in a few seconds
i'm going to give this one for what it
is
and again i didn't i don't have enough
time to go through everybody's like
every page so i apologize for that
for what i see here i'm going to give
this one a
a 3.3 or so
i think all right
all right so next up
who is next all right i have one picked
out here
this is from user colb
colby i think
all right so this is a behance.net
gallery
submission so it's it's nothing that's
realized yet it looks like it's a it's a
messenger redesigned for the iphone
so you know as a matter of trying to
practice and get better
you can do redesigns and and see that if
you you can challenge yourself to try to
come up
with something better in terms of the ui
or the ux experience of popular apps
um so looking at this real quickly
i wish you could have like a little bit
higher resolution photos to look at
this looks really solid though in my
opinion good visual hierarchy
the type looks good and well separated
between each other
um yeah this looks pretty solid in my
opinion
oops did i just click off of that oh
there we go
um this one
is a little strange to me because the
chat screen we're using two different
color schemes so this one's blue
but this one changed to uh pink
so that's a little bit confusing to me
um
i'm not sure if that's maybe
demonstrating like user
color preferences or not but if not you
don't want to do that you want to
you want to be consistent in your
application of your ui design principles
and those things being
you want to be you want to consistently
apply uh
your your usage of colors so you want to
have a color theme that you use across
the whole site and you also want to
i apply the same topography the same
type of
uh margins and padding white space on
all that stuff the scale
all that all that good stuff but outside
of that
uh this looks pretty pretty solid for
what it is
i think because there's not enough
screens and because it's not a highlight
enough resolution we won't bother
doing a rating here but it is good i
it's probably one of the highest
rated so far just by looking at this
right here
all right um let's go ahead and check
out another one
we'll do another portfolio i think
after this we'll try not to stick to
portfolio so much
let's refresh it to see if there's any
animations
wait what was that
so if you notice if i refresh this
there's like text
over these little cards and it just it
goes away really fast
why are you doing that that's strange to
me
yeah so i want to do that because that
serves no purpose there's no way a
person is going to be able to read all
them
and then it just hides so it leaves me
angered
when you do that all right now this is
cool i do like that that
is a cool way um we can hover over it
and we have a nice
uh a sequence based animation
so that that that this works pretty well
i would probably increase the padding
which will help the white space inside
of the container
because these are out a little bit too
close to the edges
so i would increase the padding there
that's pretty solid i welcome my
portfolio i specialize in ui ux design
and front and development
so what this person's doing is this
they're they're taking the
they're taking the visitor straight into
probably what they want to see the most
the work but i would still probably also
have
something down here in this big empty
open space
i that says do you like what you see
maybe you can hire me
with a button a strong call to action
outside of just having their work here
so if i click about
all right so i like that you did
something unique up here
instead of just having a paragraph about
you
uh so that that works pretty well right
here um
it's a little bit the type is a little
bit strange to me because
we have a label up here let me tell you
a bit about me
um i honestly i think what i would do
that looks nice see right here when it's
on three lines it's nice and centered
but when it's not it's kind of
it's it's pushed up a little bit so the
alignment is off
so it probably sounds like i'm really
nitpicky but these things matter
uh they matter at every re at every
viewport trying to get your site up look
at this
so these are things like if we don't
test them well enough
and we don't take this browser and drag
them in and also try to test them on
real devices that we can see
big issues somebody might be on on an
ipad
and they're looking at this and you're
like what i can't read the bottom of
this or why is this cut off
if this person makes a website for me
are they going to do this
to my site and then this could literally
something like this could literally be
the difference between
getting a two thousand dollar project
and then just not getting chosen at
all so i would i definitely make sure
you address
these issues uh as much as possible to
make sure nothing bad like that is
happening
all right so do you think this person
should get for a rating one being the
worst and 10 being the best
let me know i'm going to wait for your
answers to come in i'm not seeing them
just yet i think there's a delay
happening
i'm going to give this one
a flat out oh and by the way another
thing you know
this whole blip here should be
vertically centered so that way there's
not a big amount of white space just
sitting there
for this one i'm going to give this a
rating of
yeah i'm going to give this a
flat out just a six and it seems like a
lot of you are agreeing with me
on that based on upon a quick glance at
least
all right so we have another one here
this one is for a sas
project not the css sas but software as
a service so this is from
user uh daniel
all right so let's close this out
by the way we've been running for
54 minutes so we'll probably be over
here in about 20 minutes or so
i will keep on doing this maybe even
longer i'm not sure we'll see how this
goes
all right so this is a figma prototype
so it's not realized in the browser yet
with your html and css
so understand that and this let's see
here so
i'm not really sure what this is about
the user didn't tell me
or i didn't at least read it so unique
web
home about us pricing contact dashboard
save time with unique web
the all-in-one management solution for
your minecraft server okay
so based on that verbiage now
that we know it's a management solution
for
minecraft
why is there no visual indicator
that this is about minecraft so we're
using these
these generic sort of illustrations
probably got
from some site somewhere but they don't
say anything about
minecraft this is where creating
or either yourself but if you're not an
illustrator and most people aren't
illustrators
maybe hiring somebody to come up with a
really good
illustration for this hero section that
indic that indicates that this is about
minecraft
management so it's about thinking
uniquely
in order to create a nice relevant
graphic here because i had to read
the sub headline in order to understand
what this is about whereas if i had a
visual indicator through
either a screenshot or an illustration
like this
i would have known a little bit quicker
that they this is something about
minecraft
all right um the login button is too big
so scale is one of those things to
understand about ui design fundamentals
that will help your designs
the login button is too big in relation
to the size of all the other elements so
i would i would
i would scale that back also
does it make sense from an information
architecture standpoint to have a login
button being your primary call to action
wouldn't it perhaps be maybe something
maybe you have a free trial and you have
a get started button
that would probably perform a lot better
people who are already members
they're not going to be going back to
your website and like clicking this
they don't need to click this they'll
usually look up and click on a dashboard
or a login link
outside of that the i would change the
card background because it looks like
it's in a slightly different hue than
this background color so it's a little
strange
what i like to do um is i like to take
this the background color that is
sitting on you know what let me do this
real quick
i'll open up adobe xd and i'll show you
what i mean
because it's kind of hard to describe
what i'm talking about
um so this is going to help us just a
little bit more so let's say we get this
a similar background color
so i'll just go here and this looks like
it's it's somewhere in the blue
desaturated
right around there okay so if you're
gonna have cards like that
sorry i hid the chat let me move this
over if you're gonna have cards like
that
a great way to give them separation
is to do this so here's our card
maybe we have slightly rounded corners
what i'll do is take the background
color so now it becomes the same
background and becomes visible
and then just take this color picker and
make it
maybe slightly darker i would not
change this hue because look how ugly
that looks we start pushing up here
that's kind of what this person was
doing
it just doesn't look good so what you
would do instead
is get that same background color and
then just either make it lighter
i'm just pushing it up very just very
barely like a couple pixels
or you can make it darker
like right there and so that looks
a lot better than what you had
before right here so notice how they're
in different hues it just doesn't make
sense
it doesn't look as good outside of that
i would probably increase the line
height from your headlines right here
and then when it comes to price
comparison tables this is another great
tip you can go to dribble type in price
comparison or prices
to try to get ideas but you usually want
to emphasize one or
the other and again you do that through
ui design
um and also change your verbiage sign up
sign up sign up so that these are all
styled the same
you really want to emphasize one or the
other all right so what do you guys
think this person
should get for a rating one being the
worst and 10 being the absolute best
i'll wait for your answers to come in
for me i think i know what i'm going to
get but this one
probably
yeah again i i hate to give like all
almost all the same ratings
but this again is probably somewhere
around
like a 6.2 or so
there are some things that are happening
well here so
i mean there's a lot of good things but
those things are really taking away
from the overall score all right
i we're going to check out just a few
more
somebody said attend you must have
really loved that
all right or it was the actual user
all right well it's great to be
confident yourself right
all right so let's go ahead
and check this one out so we're going to
write we're going to refresh this
all right so there's no animation first
thing
too much white space up here in this
uh the nav bar not sure if that was
intentional or maybe it's an issue with
the html css but you want to get that
right underneath where you know these
end second
tours and travel amazing place on earth
might want to rethink that verbiage
there a little bit
um but the biggest issue is this button
this uh i can see there's a little bit
of a gradient in it
going from dark purple to lighter purple
in the middle
with explore being something that you
can barely even read
what i would do if i can change this
easily
sometimes depending on what people are
doing it's hard for me to change stuff
but this shouldn't be that difficult
the background we need to change to
white
we'll make the font weight bold
uh font size
maybe not that large like that
at this resolution this this right here
should be like four rem units
there we go that's looking better and
then this font size should be like 0.7
rem oh wait that was the margin i
changed
well you get the point uh one point or
maybe like two ram units
there we go this looks a lot better
because you're utilizing the space more
effectively because we're on this larger
viewport and it's not so small
and we've also made this call to action
stick out a lot more so contrast
is another one of those ui design
fundamentals that really helps
a design come together if i refresh
you'll see the original
and you can see just when those few
things are off
it doesn't look as good so you want to
have good contrast
especially when you're using a
photograph watermark based background
for your hero section
all right so that's a little bit uh
interesting one problem though
i can see the pixelation here i on this
so
it it looks a little bit cheap because i
could see along these bezier curves
there's pixelation occurring so you
don't want that
you can actually achieve this if you set
if you structured your html a little bit
differently and use css
to create like an svg overlap
and that way there will never be any
pixelation
looking at these cards this is one thing
i haven't seen yet um with these reviews
is using the drop shadow
drop shadows and i've done videos on
drop shadows you can
do a search on my youtube channel
they're not always bad
but i see especially you know relatively
new ui designers
they get it wrong because they they
really emphasize the drop shadows
too much so that's the case here you
want if you're going to use a drop
shadow like this a big soft one
on your cards make it very
almost unrecognizable you don't want
them to stick out
too much because it always makes it look
cheap or amateur or outdated
in terms of designs because this is
something us designers
back you know in the early 2000s we used
to do a lot of
we thought drop shadows were really cool
all the time but
that's not so much the case anymore and
that's for there's a good reason for
that and that's because people don't
really care
about your shadows they care about the
content so you want them to be
afterthought as much as possible also i
could see
these these card backgrounds are
actually transparent so that's why we
can see
this element in the background which by
the way is not svg
this element right here should
completely be an svg graphic
not a png or anything that's raster
based because i can see
all the pixelation occurring
again issue with a contrast right here
and we have a dark purple and then we're
using black text no no no no these
should be
white so people can actually read them
also an issue with alignment we see we
have a column
structured right here which is defined
by the first element being this label
but then you're pushing it over just a
little bit and it throws off the flow
of the design same thing right here
this is unnecessary to have this indent
indentation or this white space
so white space isn't always a good thing
you have to know how to apply it
correctly
a border here unnecessary don't want
that creates too much clutter
uneven alignment right here and this
button
button should be white the tag the the
actual text
so yeah there's a lot of small issues
here
and it's interesting i could probably
take this design
and make it go from a rating of about
five
probably to like eight in the matter of
30 minutes if i if i had enough time to
work with it and everything and that's
what you can do once you develop that
eye and understand the ui design
fundamentals
so what do you guys think this person
should get for writing one being the
worst and 10 being the best
we are going to do one more because my
voice
is becoming extremely scratchy we will
do one more um
and then we will conclude the show
one being the worst ten being the best
for me i'm going to go ahead and give
this a rating
let's think here um
5.6 yeah
something like that i think that's
pretty fair
all right i'm gonna check out
one more i like to screen the
submissions on my other monitor
just in case somebody decides to troll
me
uh fortunately not many people have ever
done that
all right all right here's the last one
cream digital all right
all right so how about we do something
different for this very last one
what do you think is wrong about this
section the most
let me know in the chat
like what does this suffer from the most
and i'm talking about ui design
fundamentals what like what
what is the one thing that could be
corrected to really make this design
better
i'm not asking for a rating
seriously people just spamming
a rating and i'm not even asking them
sharma said light theme alignment
bland not enough space alignment
font size and white space
too much white space it's a boring
hierarchy
all right so i would agree with the
people who said
white space of course there's i mean not
white space i'm sorry
alignment the one thing that is
immediately thrown off is
the we have a column that started right
here
uh based on the first element that we
see which is the logo
um but offset to the left
over here is their you know their their
headline
and sub headline and call to action this
should be
either moved in to match up with this
logo or
this up here should be moved out and
this
suitably being moved out as well another
issue
somebody said font size i agree it's a
little bit too small
in this sub headline right here this is
pretty good but this should be probably
beefed up a little bit more in terms of
font size same thing with the get
started caption for the call to action
also i would make instead of being it
being outlined
i would make this filled in uh
to be something that's well this is
interesting
why is the okay where's the background
background color there we go
the background should be you know
something more like that and then the
color should be white
and then font way could be bold
um is there a stroke on that it kind of
looks like there's a stroke
either way that way it stands out so
much it stands out a lot more
also i probably move it down uh because
this is all a little bit cluttered in
its own section and there's a lot of
white space another thing people said
is the white space too much white space
so i would fix those issues
the learn more button unusually too big
i would scale that down
i like the the illustration the
illustration here is pretty solid i like
this one a lot
this one's a little bit on the generic
side
cards here with a ton of white space too
much white space at the bottom as
opposed to the top so when we're adding
white space we want to try to make it
especially in the card format you want
to make it uniform
top bottom right left same white space
so probably a little bit too much white
space here um
coming down all right uh
so this section's not too bad here
we have a small call to action looks
really small
again when people scroll down you want
to give them access
to uh you know wherever it is you're
trying to direct them to every page
should have a purpose
uh the get cream button down here seems
like an afterthought
style it like this but make it white so
it really has a good contrast down here
and it would stand out much more so
let's do a final rating one being the
worst 10 being the best
let me know what you think and we'll see
if we agree and then we will conclude
what am i going to give this one let me
think here
things going right about it the
illustrations are pretty nice for the
most part
good usage of color i like the color
scheme for the most part i think a
little bit heavy on some of the
the linear gradients i like the logo a
lot
um topography is pretty good
yeah so i'm going to give this one a
flat out
let me see here
i'm going to give it like a 7 or like a
6.9
or so um and i'll probably be
one of our kind of a better ones but i
still didn't see anything that really
knocked it out of the park in my opinion
today
but nonetheless thank you all for you
know those of you who submitted now i
know
hundreds of you submitted designs and i
was only able to get through like 10 or
15.
uh but there's good news first of all
i'm gonna be doing this again
i on free code camp's channel here
uh next wednesday at the same time and
also the wednesday after that so this is
a three stream session this is the first
of three
so you guys you can all come back we'll
probably have
a new hashtag i'm not sure about that uh
for you to submit
but i'll talk with the people at free
code camp about that
and you'll have all the details they
usually announce
the uh the live stream and they they set
it there
that their youtube channel so you'll see
the details um and
also i also i do this show on my own
youtube channel
over at uh design course so youtube
user design course you can i in fact i'm
going to be doing this in two or three
days either this friday or this saturday
on my own youtube channel
and it pretty much follow the same
format except i use
my discord server for you to submit if
you wish
so go ahead and check that out also
designcourse.com that's going to be
my new relaunch site i where if you want
to master ui ux
it's going to be the most comprehensive
course i
that you can imagine there's going to be
video courses there's going to be
interactive ui design challenges there's
going to be live ui ux workshops
i'm really excited for it uh and so it's
going to be releasing in several months
time i'm not exactly sure when we're
working on it now
so check that out as well and yeah
hopefully you guys enjoyed and girls you
all enjoyed everything
that i i was able to help with and
hopefully it was helpful
so i will see everybody soon alright
goodbye